norbert vetere bonjour bonjour bienvenue
dans la matinale de rtl france alors les
non vaccinés sont confinés à partir
d'aujourd'hui en autriche selon vous est
ce que cette mesure elle a du sens pour
freiner la propagation du virus
en principe on le sait pas et en doute
que ça vaille dernier pas dans une
spirale donc le premier par fonctionne
on est dans une situation meilleure pour
tous les services de soins intensifs
donc à la fin de leur garde et et il y a
à peu près onze mille temps qu'il se
fait qu un par jour donc
on va arriver
à un point où il faut mettre en ordre
d'autres d'autres mesures précédemment
cette mesure de passes annie terre et
logan pour les gens qui n'ont pas de
passage est ce que vous savez
concrètement comment vont être
appliquées ces mesures de confinement
pourrait les non vaccinés est-ce que les
gens qui travaillent et qui ne sont pas
vaccinés vont devoir être confinés par
exemple
les gens qui travaillent si elle ils
peuvent travailler dans home office
c'était le but de cette rencontre s'ils
peuvent pas travailler dans mon mot
crise ils sont là ils sont testés tous
les jours baissière comme ça on
n'empêche pas les gens de gagner
d'argent et le travail et comment cette
mesure est elle perçue par les
autrichiens peut-être plus précisément
par la communauté médicale elle fait
l'unanimité
oui c'est l'unanimité
l'unanimité surtout chez les médecins
parce que on sait ce qu'il se passe dans
les services de soins intensifs
il y a il y a peu de gens qui sont
contre ces mesures
dans votre reportage vous avez vu des
gens ils représentent pas la majorité de
la population
déjà les premières mesures de la semaine
dernière ont été acceptés et la fa la
fréquence des nouveaux
halak ciné est augmenté donc le but
d'été
à augmenter les vaccinations et c'est
déjà fait pendant la semaine dernière et
on espère que le lock down pour les pour
les non vaccinés va augmenter la
pourcentage qui est reçu
70% de la population
elle est l ai reçu 70% ont parlé de 67 %
jusqu'à présent c'est un peu moins que
la moyenne européenne
le chef de l'exécutif parlé d'un taux
honteusement bas pourquoi les les
autrichiens 1 ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner selon vous
j'ai aucune idée et il était question
sociologique aux loges il faut poser
mais la droite a dit les gens contre
vaccination comme leur clientèle donc
samedi prochain une manifestation
sera organisée bas par la droite y est
le réseau pour les gens qui sont ceux
qui comparent à propos de la vaccination
concernant les soins intensifs le nombre
de personnes qui arrivent à l'hôpital a
doublé en moins d'une semaine en
autriche est-ce que la situation est
extrêmement critique est ce que les
quelles sont les personnes qui se
retrouvent en soins intensifs
en principe ce sont 80 % non vaccinés
20% vaccinés avec des maladies à qui
il dans une union sous pression donc la
plupart sont des gens qui sont non
vaccinés on n'est pas encore au point où
il faut retarder des opérations électif
mais on veut absolument empêcher cette
situation il faut faire un triage
merci beaucoup nord vers 20h pour votre
éclairage ce matin sur rtl france je le
rappelle vous êtes médecin sexologue
depuis vienne en autriche